Bob Cowell is a resident of Murrieta
California where an unknown number of
illegal migrants recently were brought
for processing where are they now well
that's open to question mr. Cowell joins
us live tonight Bob thanks very much for
coming on so we love you took her thanks
thanks and we're glad to have someone
from California running the front lines
of all of this giving us an account of
what is happening so people who are in
the country illegally were brought to
your town where are they what happened
to them what do you know they're flowing
in from El Paso
Sunday evening Sunday afternoon and they
brought up by bus from Brownsville
Airport in San Diego near the border to
Marietta which is about 60 miles north
that's my town and there for processing
there and the processing takes 24 48 72
hours we don't know exactly but they're
there without with one one toilet
basically have they have I understand
from the sources that I have that
there's tuberculosis there scabies and
other things that that that are right
now in our community these people go
through processing there I'm sure
they're great some of them are great
people but then they get I understand a
bus voucher and they go down to their I
told it I was told that they are taken
to the local Temecula mall which is a
neighboring town and they can take a bus
anywhere we suggest that they go to a
not a sanctuary city like Los Angeles
like shares home or San Francisco or
Portland and not Murrieta and Temecula
we our sanctuary there what yes sir just
for our viewers who are now googling
your town and Temecula who aren't from
California they're discovering that
you're nowhere near the border you're
nowhere near Mexico why are people being
flown and bused to your town who thought
of that and what's the point
do you know yes well there is a Border
Patrol station in Marietta and so there
is Border Patrol agents there and we
thank them for that
we love our station there that station
takes care of the i-15 corridor we do
they do a lot of drug busts on that on
that Highway and a lot of they used to
catch a lot of the illegal aliens on
that Highway
so they're there for another purpose
they were actually about ten miles north
of that they had a border checkpoint
exactly about 60 miles or 50 miles north
of the border by law I think they could
have that we do have those in in the
United States so that border station is
legally there but it's just it's just
interesting they're being flown from
Texas to your town all right
have you or anyone else in the town
being consulted on this is anyone asked
your opinion no actually we found out
this by by inside sources that I can't
divulge but but it's been confirmed by
the police chief a Marietta that they
are there and I was confirmed by a
Border Patrol agent senior one today
that I talked to you that yes they are
there so we know that they're there and
actually I've been told that there's a
hundred and five of them that this is
not new that they've actually been
coming in since 2014 when we had
thousands of demonstrators out on the
street in the town so I don't know if
you know about that
I do I do and and I suspect there may be
more news from your town and I hope that
you'll keep us posted on what happens
Bob Cal thanks very much for that update
I appreciate it
sure thank you